sh great now we're breaking and
entering we're terrible detectives
aren't we Addison why did you say that
Moonlighting is finally streaming you're
looking great kid for the first time
ever you're impossible and you're
ridiculous fine fine good good you mad
I'm not mad good
I'm
delived you're just as confused about as
as I am so what should we do Don't Look
Down having fun
yet remember how great things were
before what's her name showed up no
arguments no pressure no cases you're
crazy about me and I'm going to be under
your skin for a long time Buster you
know it fine fine good good just on the
way Moonlighting All Seasons now
streaming on
Hulu